my next guest the author of the book I'm
fine in other lies which is available in
a bookstore near you or online Whitney
Cummings good to see you as well how
have you been I've been ok no I mean
we're so conditioned to just say we're
fine when we're not aren't we you don't
want to hear about how my meds aren't
mixing well don't take lunesta and
thyroid medication and freeze your eggs
at the same time what's your fantasy
teams name Chris
oh so we have one rich and iShare team
vultures of the ether which is what Bob
Costas referred to social media as
vultures of the ethers I like that so we
like that okay so we kept that and Bob
Costas is the avatar the photograph of
our team okay well we're open to
switching so what happens when you play
on a fantasy team exactly well you you
watch the actual real football okay and
the yards that the players accrue okay
translate into fractions of point you
get checks in the mail from doing this I
mean I won my week last year you get
money you get money if you I don't think
I can say that because it's more than
ten it's more than the IRS will allow is
that how much money it is you never told
me that are you serious I got a fancy
trophy and yeah man hi yeah man so you
studied these men yeah yes you you look
at the men you watch them were catch
them do still study their bodies and
decide based on their talents which ones
you want to bring into your fantasy
fantasy which ones you want to fantasize
about we fantasize about these around I
do for money yes okay okay
flag sports when you describe it like
that no I fantasize about men to just I
mean not not the ones in spandex oh is
that right yeah zero is there a fantasy
league that I'm unfamiliar with it's
could there be a sportscaster
start a fantasy leave for sportscasters
you would be my top the book is about a
lot of the lies that I've told and a lot
of the lies I've lived but it's I've
come through the other side and I now
know how to tell the truth so that's
actually truthful so this is a cathartic
book for you because I have some stories
here written on a card I'd like to run
down a nightmare I know but the whole
reason I put in a book is cuz I didn't
want to have to talk about it publicly
or like make eye contact with people
because these are all the stories I
tried to tell on stage but I was too
embarrassed so I just put them in a book
so you could read them in your own so
are you are you the the type that
doesn't watch back what you do like when
you put never special oh no I watch you
just talk like Fran Drescher you
wouldn't but don't laugh at that
actually anytime the nanny is mentioned
in any way sound like French Russian
well I mean kind of sometimes after like
two shots of whiskey I sound exactly
like Fran Drescher and look like her
interesting enough so yeah I mean I
basically just you know I got sick of
being crazy you knew me back when I was
crazy yes football journey that's what
it was I got in trouble for that and I
was just I was kind of nuts everyone's
you know people her nuts you're nuts you
guys know it we can get into why Chris
Brockman's nuts shortly here yeah I have
some questions for you need Cummings I'm
fine in other lies so story you tell
having my lacerated ears sewn back on by
a deaf guy I was losing it in a torrid
love affair can we fill in the blanks
here I feel like that's pretty
self-explanatory do you actually need
more that's the why I had my ear bitten
off by a dog can you tell I can't that's
some high quality surgery right okay now
the top of it now that I'm staring I've
got a little nub there's a little cars
like a weird hemorrhoid or something
like a little tiny double right double
right there yeah I had a that is a
close-up shot no we're not in for cable
no I might be fine this is not fine in
4k I did I got my eye rescue dogs and
one of them I basically just I pulled
from a shelter the Carson shelter they
euthanize them really quickly I saw it
on Instagram I know Instagram for a lot
of you guys is for athletes and porn
stars not for me it's all dogs and it
gives me anxiety it's not fun I went
down to the shelter got him and he
didn't have spatial intelligence he
wasn't trained yet so he bit my ear
clear off my head so then a deaf guy so
debacle just any deaf guy he was a
doctor I wouldn't put it past me to just
ask a random deaf guy to sell my ear up
that is the kind of thing I would do
going to Craigslist missed connections
deaf guy yeah come on over I have some
barbed wire let's knock this out I don't
have great health insurance so I have
done insane things like that but I am a
comedian after all I have bad ideas but
but yeah so I went to the hospital and
the the basically your you know that's
warts yes ears ears okay I'm looking for
the connection you're injured like
injuries yeah athletes get injured Mike
Tyson bit Evander Holyfield's to end a
fight yeah and you get so much
adrenaline that you don't really feel
pain okay I didn't is that a sports
thing I've never had anything so I don't
know we should work on that
let's work on your brand so I'm
basically Evander Holyfield and I go and
he's sawing on my ear it hurts more
apparently to anesthetize the ear than
just to do the surgery without
anesthesia so he does it without
anesthesia
I have a very high tolerance for
emotional pain not physical pain oh my
gosh he started sewing it up and I'm
like sir can you please tell me when
you're gonna stick the needle into my
ear and he's completely ignoring me
won't like which to me I mean you guys
have dated women we like being heard we
I need to be acknowledged you probably
heard that in a fight I don't need to
solve the problem I just want you to
hear me
what very bomb yeah you're like what I
know we don't agree with me uh yeah you
know that confuses the hell out of guys
you understand what I don't you to solve
the problem I just want you to hear me
but that confuses me why number two help
well yeah we're problem solvers no but
sometimes I just need to feel validated
in my anger or rage or a frustration
like I don't want to fix it at the
moment I just want to be seen and heard
nothing that that means nothing to you
no no no no I know it means something
but I guess while we're on the subject
here cuz there's probably lots of guys
and women out there one now right now to
me I'm like what what what does that
solve
it's always about solving and my wife
will always say I don't want to solve
anything right right right
cuz because I think that I mean for me
I've worked so hard to not be reactive
and react when I'm emotional to
something because I'm just sending an
email where you're saying something you
shouldn't say you're calling somewhat
like for me I'm like I don't want to
take an action right now I don't want to
act insane and my emotion I just want to
talk it through and I'll take an action
in a couple days and I've cooled off you
guys need to understand that sports
okay I'm gonna relate this back to
sports but so to me it's like I mean
from when I was in my 20s and I was
crazy I just would like go off on people
I thought like a 10 I was just like a
nut I'm driving around ex-boyfriends
houses um it's not a good luck for me so
sometimes I just want to talk through
something and just make sure I'm not
crazy I usually am instead of bring it
all full circle and put a button on it
yeah I thought the doctor was ignoring
you and I was on thanks why you trying
to come full circle
why are you acting like that this show
needs to have some kind of because
they're an if structure I just I just do
if you bring so talented any indication
that I'm interested in as being a
professional interview I feel like I'm
trying to solve the story instead of
something you've changed a little bit
this man started dating
dating my friend he's being very quiet
over there last time I was in the show a
lot chattier I want to take a 60-second
break yeah I'm back I know
bracelets yes I noticed she started
wearing them did you go to Bali why are
you wearing bracelets all of a sudden
Marshall Faulk wears him oh we're back
it's not even me we're back we're back
in 60 seconds with Whitney Cummings here
on the show welcome back to the Rich
Eisen show I didn't wear a bra and I'm
getting very nervous okay coming by the
way it's really strange we had Peter
Farrelly on the show yesterday he didn't
say that at all he did he wear bra he
was not he was not concerned about a
single situation it is this is not a
great angle this isn't a good luck I
need to do more sports you look great
and that's not a one of those lies that
you're talking about fine and otherwise
in a bookstore
and online near you now you Whitney
Cummings Whitney Cummings on Twitter by
the way just to actually do bring it
full circle yeah the guy who was sewing
your ear back on was in fact death was
in fact to have my friend called the
next day this the surgeon was sewing up
my ear I was asking him for a three
count right three two one on three after
three would was completely ignoring me
I'm like this doctor is so dismissive
he's such an egomaniac he's such a jerk
the next day my friend called the doctor
to say like hey when should she get her
stitches taken out and they were like oh
the doctor can't speak he's deaf like if
your doctors deaf shouldn't they give
you a heads-up surgeon why why do you
want to know that wouldn't it make you
more anxious and more freaked out about
it's about to happen if I knew the
doctor was deaf yeah I know at least
know why he's completely ignoring me I
got a lot of men completely ignore me in
my day while I'm yelling so I just
assumed it was yet another man then
don't you want the doctor to just solve
the problem if any man that you're
talking to you want to just solve the
problem solution so ninety years old you
have a girlfriend so I'm trying to solve
problems just live in the problem let's
get to that right
what is happening so just Sarah make you
wear this bracelet so that other girls
don't want to date you so let's just
that's a great way to see the bracelet
highly talented comedian the greatest
she's a dear friend of mine so you guys
are tight tight very okay yeah now
before we get into the bracelets before
I'm gonna get him off the hook a little
bit right there hmm when did when did
Chris Brockman first come into your life
actually I mean I kind of knew about you
but I didn't know it was you cuz you and
I had met before she tried to like keep
it under wraps to make sure that you
weren't a sociopath for a while so it's
kind of only in the last couple months
that I've really been here knowing it
was you so no wonder she kept you a
secret
she was very ashamed of you for a long
time because out of you both shady not
everything is for public consumption
rich well his Instagram is at Brock
Shady yeah oh yeah red flag you guys but
it's interesting because she's Sarah I
never thought that Sarah would find a
guy who was smart I will give you this
compliment who was smart enough
interesting enough she's wicked smart
wicked funny she's beautiful what are
you looking why are you looking up he's
deep down inside begging us for it to
get to another topic I know this guy and
she's she is a delight she's a delight
she's one of my dearest friends one of
the only people I trust in this world
although I'm starting to lose a little
bit of respect that she's letting you
wear so much jewelry so what is with the
the beads is this like you know a shoes
you from Albuquerque were you did you go
on a retreat in Santa cool no Marshall
wears them I'm Marshall Faulk stop
taking fashion advice from athletes
he actually is a terrific fashion sense
I must say can you pull up a photo of
this man we can I don't cool it's like
water
it's a water and ice from Mount Everest
and mud from the Dead Sea and they put
them in these bracelets and it's
supposed to talk about hopefulness and
humbleness it's it no that's very zen of
you remarkably Zen for a guy who is a
total Masshole otherwise it's just to
get let you in on a window in a way of a
guy-guy situation here I noticed the
beads or whatever you got over here as I
noticed them was about two weeks ago you
started wearing it yeah let it go I
didn't ask I didn't it's just like
another guy doesn't say to another guy
like why when you know what's with the
beads on your wrist so I'm hanging out
with Russell Brand I mean I'm just
saying in general don't take fashion
advice from men that shop at Big & Tall
we're the same size
so you know what it all comes down to it
she is a lovely girl she's the greatest
and so in in the in a in a comedian
circuit yeah is he known as her
boyfriend I know people respect you a
lot
I can I don't know why but they do yeah
no I think I think that we always were
like nervous like Sarah's never gonna be
able to find a guy who can like match
her like she needs like a match so I
think people have a lot of respect for
you that you can handle is she a
commitment-phobe as well um kind of yeah
you two are perfect for each other
that's Kirk's in the wind do you is it
because I'm now that I've got my life
together I feel like I'm ready for a
healthy relationship is it important for
healthy relationship for two people to
support the same sports teams don't know
cuz you guys aren't fans the same team
no actually she's a Falcons fan I'm a
Patriots fans and although they for the
Falcons at the Patriots Superman's at
the Super Bowl last year and if you
didn't break up then I don't think
you'll break up my wife is a
Red Sox fan I'm a Yankee fan she's a
patriot fan I grew tension this is well
it causes tension when you have children
okay because when you have children you
have to they have to pick a side well
not really pick a side it's when the
other side of the family starts sending
Red Sox bibs to the house like seeing
your child walk around in those it's
it's it's a trail well what ends up have
to do is there has to be compromised
yeah there has to be something when you
come together as a family and what is a
compromise well that as a jet fan
growing up and the Patriots are winning
over and over and over again yeah I have
to
it would be like Child Services would
take my choice the other thing okay yeah
but the and then I drew a line at the
Yankees great that has to be low I mean
I did talk about this in my book I used
to think that in order to be in a
healthy relationship you had to
basically take on the characteristics of
the other person like I used to have
like every Jersey in my closet from all
the guys I dated I had like Redskins
Dolphins Dallas Cowboy whatever yeah my
house is like a footlocker I just had
like every Jersey and then now that I've
sort of got it together and I have
self-esteem and I have confidence I can
proudly say I am I should be safe so I'm
Redskins fan there you go I have to be
art monk vultures of the you know he's
very much not very much he's in the Pro
Football Hall of Fame but that's okay
other lives I'm fine otherwise check it
out in a bookstore followed by Art Monk
is dead yes exactly
you see Whitney Whitney Cummings on
Twitter check out yes I'm fine in other
lies go get the book lots of fun Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country
and audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy